D
SONS ARE, AND IF THEY'RE ALIVE.
SOME ARE REACHING OUT TO UKRAINE
TO FIND OUT.
>> HELLO.
IS THIS WHERE ONE CAN FIND
OUT --
>> HELLO, DO YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT MY HUSBAND?
>> Reporter: THESE ARE THE
VOICES OF RUSSIANS, PARENTS,
WIVES, SIBLINGS DESPERATELY
SEARCHING FOR ANSWERS, CALLING
TO FIND INFORMATION, ANYTHING ON
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS THEY'VE LOST
CONTACT WITH, WHO ARE FIGHTING
IN UKRAINE, WHO MAY BE WOUNDED,
CAPTURED, OR EVEN KILLED.
>> Reporter: THIS RUSSIAN WIFE,
LIKE MANY OTHERS, HAS TURNED TO
AN UNLIKELY SOURCE FOR HELP, THE
UKRAINIANS.
IN THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
BUILDING, CHRISTINA, WHICH IS
HER ALIAS, IS IN CHARGE OF A
HOTLINE CALLED COME BACK FROM
UKRAINE ALIVE, WHICH UKRAINE'S
INTERIOR MINISTRY SAYS HAS
GOTTEN OVER 6,000 CALLS.
CHRISTINA ASKS THAT WE DON'T
SHOW HER FACE.
YOUR COUNTRY IS BEING INVADED,
BUT YOU ALSO FEEL THE NEED TO
HELP THESE RUSSIAN FAMILIES.
WHY?
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE
]
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIAN
RELATIVES WHO HAVE CALLED THIS
HOTLINE SAY THEY HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM THEIR SOLDIERS SINCE THE
INVASION.
THE HOTLINE, WHICH RUSSIAN
FAMILIES HAVE FOUND ON SOCIAL
MEDIA OR THROUGH WORD OF MOUTH,
GAVE CNN EXCLUSIVE RECORDINGS OF
A NUMBER OF THE CALLS.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> Reporter: WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE CALLS THAT STICK OUT TO YOU
THAT YOU REMEMBER THE MOST?
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
.
>> Reporter: THESE ARE THE NOTES
FROM ONE OF THE CALLS.
AND IN FACT, THIS CALL CAME FROM
THE UNITED STATES, THE RELATIVE
OF A YOUNG RUSSIAN SOLDIER
TRYING TO FIND HIM.
SHE TOLD THE UKRAINIANS THAT HIS
PARENTS ARE NO LONGER ALIVE,
THAT THE GRANDMOTHER IN RUSSIA
IS QUITE SICK.
WE HAVE HIS BIRTHDAY.
HE IS JUST 23 YEARS OLD, AND HE
WAS LAST KNOWN TO BE IN CRIMEA
RIGHT BEFORE THE INVASION.
NOW, THE UKRAINIANS DON'T HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ON HIM, BUT IF
THEY DO FIND HIM OR GET SOME
INFORMATION, THEY CAN THEN CALL
HIS AUNT BACK IN UNITED STATES.
DATA FROM THE HOTLINE SHOWS
THOUSANDS OF CALLS NOT JUST FROM
ALL ACROSS RUSSIA BUT ALSO FROM
EUROPE AND UNITED STATES.
>> HELLO, IS THIS --
>> YES, IT IS.
>> Reporter: WE GOT THROUGH TO
THREE RELATIVES WHO CALLED THE
HOTLINE, INCLUDING A RELATIVE IN
VIRGINIA, OF ONE WHO ALSO FOUND
THE SOLDIER'S ID AND PHOTOS ON
THE CHANNEL OF A SOCIAL MEDIA
APP, TELEGRAM, ALSO DEDICATED TO
FINDING THE WHEREABOUTS OF
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS.
>> WE DO REALIZE THAT ALL THE
LINES ARE POINTING TO THAT MOST
LIKELY HE IS KILLED IN ACTION.
BUT WE ARE TRYING TO OBTAIN THE
INFORMATION WHERE HIS BODY THAT
CAN BE POTENTIALLY FOUND.
>> THE RUSSIAN MILITARY DEFENSE
TELLING ANYTHING TO THE FAMILY?
>> NOT YET CONTACTED BY ANYBODY.
EVERYONE IS SCARED IN RUSSIA.
EVERYONE IS SCARED TO TALK.
>> MARINA TOLD US HER COUSIN'S
PARENTS HAVE HAD NO CONTACT WITH
HIM, NO INFORMATION ON
WHEREABOUTS, OR ON HIS
CONDITION.
>> ARE THEY BEING TOLD ANYTHING?
>> NO, NO.
THEY TRIED TO FIND HIM.
BUT, LIKE, NO ONE HAS ANSWERED.
>> IS THAT WHY YOU CALLED THIS
UKRAINIAN HOTLINE?
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHY I TRIED TO
CALL, YES.
>> DID YOU GET ANY INFORMATION?
>> NO, NOTHING.
I WAS, YOU KNOW, HOPING THAT HE
IS IN PRISON OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, THAT HE'S STILL ALIVE.
>> Reporter: THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE CALLS DO NOT RESULT IN
IMMEDIATE INFORMATION FOR THE
FAMILIES.
BACK IN KYIV, CHRISTINA MAKES
CLEAR THAT THE CALL CENTER ISN'T
JUST DESIGNED TO OFFER ANSWERS
BUT TO GALVANIZE RUSSIANS
AGAINST THE WAR.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> Reporter: SYMPATHY FOR
FAMILIES, BUT ALSO ONE MORE